what we saw for x janet is traveling at 100 miles per hr.(mph).
and rohan travels at 120 mph.
great work if we found these 2 answers.
To start solving these equation we will cross multiply .
this is really the same as multiplying by the lcd of x(x+20) on both sides.
if we multiply this side by x(x+20) we will be left with 250(x+20) .
and if we multiply this side by x(x+20) we will be left with 300x.
since the x+20 reduced to one.
now I won't show that for the rest of the lesson but whenever we cross multiply we should
understand thats what we are really doing.
so 250(x+20)=300x we distribute 250 to both of the terms to get 250x+5000=300x
we subtract 250xfrom both sides to began to isolate x.
so 5000=50x.
and then finally we divide both sides by 50 to get x is equal to 100(100=x).